it is great to have back with us today
Rob Larson who's a professor of
economics and also author of the book
bit tyrants the political economy of
Silicon Valley Rob great to have you on
thanks Dave great to be here so when I
was on the Joe Rogan program a few
months ago we had this exchange where he
started talking about how of course a
company like Google is a liberal company
and it was an interesting conversation
because it seemed that what he was
talking about was you know does Google
have a policy about anti-trans bullying
and that type of thing and I pointed out
listen Google is a company that is
advocating for less regulation is
advocating for at a financial level
against some of the antitrust interests
that the people may have and may want to
have exercised through their government
and so if they you know have an internal
policy where you can't misgender people
that's not really making them a liberal
company when you consider the sort of
broader circumstances of where they are
in the world of regulation and not
paying taxes and so on and so forth what
is the right way that we should sort of
think about the political orientation of
these big tech companies that often have
a sort of progressive ish seeming public
side but behind the scenes are really
very similar to you know an oil company
or whatever else the case may be yeah
right on well that's you know very true
these companies definitely do affect a
very you know whoa very pro diversity
sort of public posture but to me I think
based on my research there what right
way to sort of frame this issue is to
look at it from the point of view of
what the company wants and then what
like the workforce wants if you sort of
dig into it a lot of the time when
people talk about how these companies
are liberal and they're so on the Left
it sounds goofy because these are after
all publicly traded corporations whose
stock is held by the wealthier
households of our society and big
financial institutions how could they be
leftist and anti-capitalist I think a
lot of the confusion is people look at
what yeah the workforce is saying and
then compute that to the company like
well the company must be liberal then
but of course as we've seen just unless
several months we've had a couple of
fairly significant labor actions against
Google where the workforce various
components of its enormous workforce are
doing walkouts and going on small
strikes and doing independent organizing
and just lately I mean I think maybe the
ultimate rebuttal to claims these
companies are liberal it's just lately
Google has been retaining the same
classic union-busting you know anti
labor organization law firms that
Walmart and Microsoft have been hiring
for years you know and especially too
when you look at the interface with
public policy in the face of all these
new investigations that big tech
including Google are subject to what
they call the tech lash you know so
could the congressional investigations
the FTC and Justice Department of probes
and the state attorneys general as well
Google is now one of the biggest
lobbying firms in Washington spending
maybe million a year more than all of
its tech peers more than Amazon even on
lobbying the government of course they
play a big role in election financing
both directly and through their packs so
to me what I would just suggest to folks
like mr. Rogan is it's really worth
taking a small amount of time to
differentiate between what the labor
force is pushing for and what the
company wants and then yes like policies
letters say for example diversity
oriented for a richer representative
staff is in like protecting the rights
of trans workers versus like the real
money aspect of the equation which the
firms are most interested in all the
lobbying and maintenance of their
monopolies Google got the FTC to just
stop investigating investigating it
during the Obama years like that's where
these bodies are buried one of the big
differences between tech companies and a
lot of other companies is that there's
often some kind of almost like a fairy
tale a romanticized story about the
origins of the company you know Mark
Zuckerberg invented it and it has been
his Harvard dorm room invented Facebook
Jeff Bezos was in some job he hated and
you know had the idea to start Amazon
and whatever else you don't see that
with a lot of other types of companies
that many of us interact with regularly
whether they be car companies of you
know airline companies or whatever the
case may be
I'm curious whether part of that is
because a lot of those other companies
have just been around much longer so the
story of their creation seems less
relevant because it's further away or is
there something more has there been a
concerted effort to keep the mystique
through these sort of fairy tale origin
stories yeah yeah that's a great
question I think we have pretty much
those are the two dynamics if you look
at all of our great blue-chip fortune
500 companies including your classic old
accompany Giants you know GM and so on
or Ford knew IBM they all have this very
folksy yes small business I developed
this company in my mom's basement in the
depression sort of origin mystique it's
true these companies are all much
younger of course you know several of
them are only 10 20 years old so their
origin story is more recent and
therefore more foregrounded but also
just because of the information based
nature of these products there's a
little bit more of a but how did you get
the great idea for this company because
since their information base the idea
for their platforms and for their
services is kind of more of the core of
the whole business than it is if you're
manufacturing light bulbs and stuff so
it's true like there really is that
small business started in a garage
mystique but of course as I look at in
one of the chapters of the book the
firms vary of course but very typically
their origins in terms of their
technology comes straight from the
public sector so Google again it's a
classic case people talk about you know
Sir Jay and pate Sergey Brin and Larry
Page they had the idea to start the firm
as this great idea and they built all
these great businesses sense I just want
to remind people Google's original web
address wasn't google.com it was Google
dot stanford.edu because they developed
that at Stanford research labs in their
computer science program one of the
great publicly funded research
university campuses in the United States
where you've got stable funding and you
are allowed to indulge your intellectual
curiosity and think freely about what
would make a good search engine or what
would make a good social networking
system in the marketplace you're under
near-term pressures for
profitability to get your stock price up
and keep Wall Street happy with you in
the academic world you're free to take
your time and of course the internet
itself after all was originally
developed by DARPA you know the
Pentagon's research arm along with the
university system and in the book I just
go through you know Amazon Facebook
Google and the internet and the hardware
itself like the stuff in your smartphone
you know almost all of that technology
comes from one or another public sector
research institution or at least through
heavy public funding which again
insulates you from that short-term
market pressure so to me the story of
the origins of these firms is one of the
juiciest phony aspects about them well
so to stick with that a little bit can
you talk a little bit about what sort of
regulatory or financial incentives also
existed that allowed these companies to
do what they did and to grow as quickly
as they did I mean certainly at a base
level people increasingly dependent on
the internet and more and more of
day-to-day society being run through the
internet is a huge boon to a company
that exists on mobile phones and on the
internet for sure but in terms of
regulation tax breaks etc what else was
done that allowed these companies to
grow so quickly at the start for sure
well the very loose regulatory framework
is an important part of this story all
through the era when the internet and
internet-based services were becoming
more popularized like in the I'm old
enough to remember in the 90s when the
internet came to town and you could go
to some library campuses and look up
other card catalogs like at that time it
was a bipartisan view that what you
don't want to do is regulate the
internet or online industries because
that's gonna impose new costs on them or
limit their you know their innovation
and their creativity and for the longest
time like well through the Bush years
into the Obama years that was something
that was more or less bipartisan we
don't want to regulate the net it's
growing it's giving us all these fun
free services and so on now of course as
these firms have become so important and
as you say is we're so reliant on them
and we start seeing their power in
elections in our society and the way
that we do with everything through our
phones people are a lot more interested
in
putting some leashes on their behavior
and on their power but to me the real
issue with having had such a loose
regulatory framework for so long for big
tech is what I talked about in the first
chapter of the book these are markets
that are subject to what we call Network
effects in economics a network effect is
just something that applies to certain
markets where an information based
product is at play and the big thing
there is that with those sort of markets
the service gains value the more people
use it so like a telephone you know as
more people get on the phone network
your telephone gets a little bit more
valuable to you cuz there's more and
more people you can potentially call
well the same Network effects apply to
companies like Facebook you want to be
on the network that has all your friends
on it not on the one that has no one on
it and Google search even there's more
people to do Google searches day in and
day out
there are algorithms keep learning from
that and the more search searches that
are done the stronger their algorithm
and search processes become so the thing
about network effects is there a strong
incentive that leads to monopolization
or maybe having two or three very
dominant firms in a market and that is
what we see in big tech from Facebook's
and instagrams
you know oligopoly - you know Google's
mobile search monopoly - YouTube there's
a long list but it's all these straight
economic aspects to it
so there was a big deal made when Amazon
basically after being shamed by Bernie
Sanders decided that they were going to
start paying everybody 15 bucks an hour
and the end result I thought was great
of course it was a calculation for
Amazon that there was going to be a PR
benefit more than likely that in the
long term would exceed the additional
cost to them of paying the 15 bucks an
hour but let's ignore that for a second
let's imagine that it worked in that an
elected official shamed a company and
they made the right decision when Donald
Trump between being elected and
inaugurated
went to I believe it was Indiana or Iowa
Indiana and announced that he struck a
deal with carrier Air Conditioner that
they were going to keep their factory
open in Indiana and what he basically
did was just give him money right there
was a plan where carrier decided we're
leaving and from
and said hey here's some money if you
stay my criticism at the time was this
is not a scalable economic policy this
is saying hey I found a company that has
already made a business decision I'm
changing the calculus by giving them
some cash and of course in the end that
money was used to start automating away
those jobs anyway half of the workforce
still went to Mexico it was a disaster
there's not that much of a difference in
a sense between Trump giving money to
carrier to get them to stay and Bernie
pressuring one company to pay 15 bucks
an hour now of course the the one that
Bernie did is working out much better in
terms of his result its results but my
question is about the scalability of
policy when it comes to these things we
can't really be relying on elected
officials to be making one-off deals can
we I mean it seems to me that we need
something systemic to be done about
regulation and incentives job creation
whatever the case may be oh absolutely
and I think even like across the wide
spectrum of opinions about big tech I
think that that is sort of recognized so
again whether you're suspicious of big
tech from a more left or a more
conservative point of view I think
broadly it's recognized what you need
yeah it's a set of stable rules that are
uniform from one company to another
yeah and stable across time you can't
just be piecemeal threatening or
throwing cash at these firms but again
what it sort of comes back to though is
the power of these firms like most
companies couldn't get all of America's
cities to debase themselves and beg for
a second headquarters but Amazon
absolutely was able to do that and it
was quite a spectacle and they ended up
splitting the investment and walking
away from New York and then of course
putting tens of thousands of jobs there
anyway without millions of dollars in
cash which kind of shows perhaps the
lack of necessity for these huge subsidy
and incentive packages but hopefully
with these new investigations we have
coming down at the national level and
indeed the international level of these
big tech firms and we do have the FTC
and the Justice Department here and it
oversees like the strongest regulations
so far that any of these firms are
subject
is all emanating from the European Union
from privacy to data storage to the
right to be forgotten it's interesting
and of course I talked about it in the
book a bit because the difference in
these regulatory conditions plus it does
end up mattering that all of these big
tech platform companies and their
monopolies or semi monopolies they are
all American and the European Union is
used to being partially dominated by
American firms you know from IBM to coke
but they're a little more willing to
regulate firms that are out of state
despite a real political presence that
those firms have overseas to but I think
a new rules based approach is very
reasonable especially one that limits
the power of these firms again we have a
fairly long record now of all of these
firms once network effects builds up
their market power from Microsoft all
the way to Google and Facebook they
aren't shy about using it to crush
competitors and destroy rivals I
mentioned this in the book there's just
a piece of Wall Street Journal reporting
about Facebook and they didn't seem to
be using this word ironically but they
mentioned that Facebook has a whole
little division in the company whose job
is to monitor startups you know new
small web-based firms that might
potentially compete with Facebook or one
of its other apps like Instagram or
messenger and they try to buy up that
firm at a very early stage when they can
buy for just a million bucks from some
founder in their garage or crush it or
go after it legally in some other way
and the way the journal described it was
Facebook is out to disrupt any potential
challengers which is kind of funny
because of course all these firms talked
about is how we're disruptors and we're
breaking up that inefficient old economy
now that they're the economy and the
five biggest companies in the US are all
these tech platforms now which is
unheard of they try to disrupt and you
know put control over their upstarts and
small competitors too so I think rules
that Lane in these firms power or even
go further in putting the work force
more in charge or you know and in that
way potentially partially socializing
the platforms to me those are the things
we should look at things that address
the firm's market power no question
about that we've been speaking with Rob
Larsen who's a professor of economics
the book is called bit tyrants the
political economy
of Silicon Valley we are linking to the
book definitely check it out Rob always
a pleasure having you on thanks Dave my
pleasure